I think that communication failure has
always happened but I think due to our
kind of modern ways of living it's
exacerbated there's always going to be
misleading and miss reading of
information
my work is photography it still has a
photography language to it I kind of
always been on the parameters of what
photography is I've always seen it as my
task my my my struggle is was to push
photography as far as it can go and see
what this kind of medium can do and how
we can talk about it I don't see the
point in standing still I constantly see
the point in challenging myself and the
medium I have shown in Paris before I've
shown in group shows before in France
never a solo show and it's been a really
interesting experience I'm always really
intrigued by how the front French
audience or so seems to be very eager to
experience art and culture in this
exhibition we've got painting machinery
and photographs too and constructions I
have used my starting point with a quote
from Willy Wonka in a chocolate factory
it's got some of the most important
metaphors for me in regards to how I
make my work like the chewing gum
machine where he takes him into this
laboratory he hits the button and it
makes all of this noise but then
eventually all it does is spitting out a
piece of gum
the kids say gum is that all it's done
but then the gum is chewed by violet and
then she starts chewing a three-course
meal that's a little bit like
research and making work in it there's
kind of a lot of banging around and a
lot of noise but then it kind of gets
belted out and quite a reductive sense
this show is quite a reductive show but
if you start chewing then hopefully it
starts bringing around questions using
black and white cuts the noise down of
the world and it gives me a very basic
template to work with the audiences the
receiver the artist is the sender and
somewhere in the middle is the noise
where someone's trying to get a message
across and someone's trying to
understand and it's that little bit that
kind of is is it's all that it's the
interesting bit
yes it's been a really good opportunity
sometimes we care you can become too
entrenched in your clique or in your
situation and it's a great opportunity
for artists to be able to go and
experience different cultures in
different scenes is vital it really is
you